paul george will start on demar derozan
he is an exceptional defender as many
know
comes right back to answer
this is one of the best bench units in
the nba this year in terms of minutes
and point production
[Applause]
navigating against a couple of defenders
[Applause]
as far as his
his rebounding and also defensively oh
yeah
[Applause]
the tombs got eight in the quarter and a
game-high eleven
derozan buchevich levine white and osumu
back out there
io two fakes the jumper rolls home over
jacksonville jackson comes back picked
off by derozan
numbers for the bulls
to the rim there you go and and that's
where he's so effective in the open
court
derozan and morris are both in the top
five in percentage of points from the
mid-range this year
so what do you get both guys battling in
the mid-range there's derozan into
double figures with six in the quarter
now i'm talking about maybe inserting
him into a starting lineup of sorts so
he'll take the spot of caruso to start
this quarter and derozan picks up where
he left off in the second
[Music]
derozan
splitting the defense shooting over
zubats
[Music]
[Applause]
jackson had 11 in the first half he's
got 11 in the third quarter alone
[Music]
it feels like a rare three-point make
tonight the sixth for the bulls they're
back within
13.
he worked out with brian shaw a lot
during his time down a lot of cardio so
he's got his wind at the very least
it's corrosion
he's got nine
number nine
now 14 points with it it's derozan for
three
everything's coming up derozan
[Applause]
double on derozan
gets to the spot
that's a thing of beauty i mean
seriously
[Applause]
with a chance at a three-point play okay
he's going to back him down there's
gonna go right by him right here boom
and he lowers his shoulder gets contact
with the left hand finishes strong
debo out here bullying people in the
boat
give me that chain
my grandmother gave me that check
five point game and 100 ticks to go
derozan to the spot
[Applause]
big time players make big time plays
he was an mvp
candidate and this is why he's the king
of the fourth
here we go wolves down three they've
trailed by as many as 16 tonight
[Applause]
he'll run into the ribbon jam it down
again
we'll go tomorrow now iso against
[Applause]
wow
here it is right here potty roof rock
say wee wee
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
patrick williams comes up big again all
his helps up top
watch patrick williams right there that
high arcing three
looking for derozan in the post he's got
it
and he's got three turn
game set match
a 50 piece to put it away in the month
of march